Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
I think fuck boy is one of my favorite.
Oh,
fuck.
Fuck boy.
It's the PC version of faggot.
I like,
fuck boy.
If I can't say Faggot,
I'm going to say fuck boy.
Sounds like you're already doing it here.
Fuck boy,
boy,
boy.
Boy.
It sounds like you're already doing it.
You're already doing it.
You're already doing,
do we know who did that one?
Yeah,
that was,
uh,
Ali.
Uh,
my food.
I love it.
Oh,
did one of the,
he did 100.
Would you rather?
It was really good.
Did he do the one week?
Right.
Good.
Nice work,
Ali.
Thank you very much.
Um,
check it out.
I'm going to sperm can Washington,
uh,
also know is known as folk Compton.
Oh.
Or a SPAC of Stan,
I guess it so down.
They get busy and Spokane.
I'm there at the,
uh,
Spokane Comedy Club on,
what's it called?
Thursday.
Friday,
Saturday this week.
What's the full charge?
That's pretty exciting.
Baby's daddy and the concierge.
Baby's dad years.
Uh,
what else?
Jacksonville,
Florida.
That's now you say that.
I say that Jack.
Jack Herer.
I know I've gotten a ton of good submissions.
I Dunno,
I can't
Jack Kerrville,
red band blue man,
I dunno.
Whatever.
We fucked up on that one.
May 5th,
sixth,
seventh and spoke in Jacksonville,
Florida comedy zone,
then a sewer juice New York.
The funny bone there is just too may 20 and 21 I can't wait to go there.
I've never been to Syracuse.
Suck my juice.
[inaudible] juice.
Um,
and then Irvine is now on sale.
Sperm,
sperm bine or per vine and your Ein.
You're out in California,
the Improv.
June nine,
10 and 11.
And of course Jew port titties in September at Caroline's is on sale as is.
Fill her dealt fill her up.
Delphia Trocadero theatre November 19th,
that is more than halfway sold even though it's,
it's quite a ways out.
So get your tickets now,
Tom,
cigarette.com/shows genes.
Uh,
this Wednesday on the 20th of April.
When is it time by Hitler,
I handlers birthday Ventura Comedy Club.
And then May 27th of May 28th a level a comedy store.
And then most Saturdays,
I'm at the comedy store here in Hollywood.
I usually do the 8:00 PM shell cause I have a baby jeans to come home.
Yeah.
Oh listen to that steep bro.
Uh,
this week I talk about this girl who wrote in who is jealous of the porno girls
that her boyfriend watch it.
Ooh,
that was kind of interesting.
Ooh.
Also genes.
If do you shop on Amazon?
I know you do.
Please use our banner,
uh,
your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on that banner at the bottom of the homepage.
Do Your shopping as you normally when I'll start shelves and I have a big
announcement the after three years I am bringing back,
charge it to the game.
The football.
That's chips in a bowl.
That's a cat eating kibble.
I don't know why you're not.
That's a huge,
now I'm,
it's a huge announcement.
I'm very,
very,
very excited to do it.
I had to get a whole new RSS because it's been so long,
but,
but listen,
we're going to try to do it even.
We're going to do a pre-draft episode this week to go up Thursday and then I'm
going to continue to do episodes in the weeks that follow.
I'm
just off season episodes talking to players,
talking to a sportswriters,
so I'm really excited to do it.
Lots of college and NFL talk should be a lot of fun.
Cool.
Hold on,
press pause for one minute.
Okay.
Just because I want to make sure my audio sounds good because I sound,
I don't know if it's these cans,
they sound,
I sound like I'm in a 10 cam.
Okay.
All right.
I just wanted to make sure everyone can hear my beautiful voice,
you know?
Absolutely.
I'm such a lovely singing voice and as always you can send your emails to your
mom's podcast,
your mom's podcast@gmail.com there's no house,
uh,
there is a Facebook page that you can like and you can post on.
We post there pretty often.
It's a facebook.com/your mom's house podcast and of course always remember that
Linkedin is helpful.
Linkedin,
it's very helpful if you want to.
Did you mention the youtube page as well that people should subscribe?
No,
go ahead.
You're already watching us.
Hopefully on youtube subscribe.
Right?
And that way you can get,
we,
we drop stuff.
When does it,
the drop date's blue Tuesday,
Tuesday nights at 11:00 PM Pacific specific.
Um,
the episode comes out in on Youtube and then basically at midnight the audio
releases.
Okay.
But there's also fun little clips.
Yeah.
Behind the scenes and all kinds of stuff.
So check out the youtube channel and subscribe please.
Yeah,
yeah,
we did it.
We got through it.
Let's do it.
You ready to get the show on the road?
Ah,
I'm really excited.
We've got so much to catch up on with listeners.
So much has happened in the last week.
Yeah,
man,
it was your birthday and we did stuff.
So now we've settled.
Let's,
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Whoa.
What the fuck?
How did that,
oh my gosh.
God dammit.
All these technical difficulties today.
No.
See if I can make this work.
All right.
Hello God,
that is the fattest person I've ever seen it.
There's this guy's manual.
Your rebate.
The world's fattest man.
Here we go.
Raise started show.
Yup,
let's go.
So now we've settled on a white picket fence.
Tell me bones sticking out.
Pegging class.
What's pegging?
Pegging is pegging is
when a dude has sex with another dude.
I wasn't begging.
Don't bring in one loving to this.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
No,
a
little bit of the East street face.
He did that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
Kevin.
He did what?
So Fun to talk shit about Springsteen on social media like post up cause he
have,
he has such a hardcore fans.
Basically if I write something about him or Donald Trump on social media,
there's always backlash,
which is really,
really amazing.
Well Springsteen is like a rock God wrapped in a an American flag,
right?
You cannot talk shit on the Boston.
They call him the boss and so serious that it's is.
That's why it's fun to say that shit about them though.
I know he's not.
He's not that terrible is he?
Is He really needs that.
I don't think he's the worst.
No,
it's not the worst.
It's a fun game to play
here.
I just think it's funny to me,
it's just funny how people worship him.
Worship.
That's really the part that's kind of,
if he was just like,
oh yeah guys,
great.
It would be different.
But when people are like
crazy,
so to be like that guy sucks and see people go like fuck
right.
People get really,
I did a post on Instagram.
We're at the rock hall of fame.
Right.
Just put thumbs down in front of a picture of him when I was there and I go,
this guy sucks.
Oh my God.
I got a lot of heat.
A lot of blow back on that one.
Huh?
And then Trump you something shitty about Trump I did on Instagram,
man.
It's just amazing.
Like people really get fucking fired up about the dumbest guy we've ever had
involved in anything.
So burnt Chrysler,
who you saw,
right?
There
was talking and actually last week we did this show and then the like five
minutes after we were done doing the depth.
So we got a notification that are new,
that are segment on not safe with Nikki Glaser was going to air.
We're like,
oh,
we could've talked about it right before it aired.
Just stopped taping this show with Jon Sachs.
So Nikki Glaser has got a new show on comedy central called not safe with Nikki
Glaser.
She covers all these really taboo topics and she approached us as a couple to do
the topic of pegging and begging class.
Yeah,
it's Super Fun.
We'll put this on the website,
but just to give,
I think what we shouldn't play the whole fucking thing.
It's on thousand ranch.com two oh,
it's up there now?
Yeah.
Okay,
so this is just a little little touch intercourse where a woman inserts a strap
on Dildo into the anus of her male partner.
I like how Bert thought it was the name that the pegging is when a guy fucks a
guy that's just called fucking,
yeah,
that's just how they fought.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
this is a straight act as a stray people by fucking Christina
I 12 years I've been threatening him with tagging,
but clearly you've shown interest in having your behind stimulated.
You want to finger?
I've wanted yes.
Finger.
You've given the finger.
No,
no,
don't even do that.
My boyfriend's into stuff back there.
He just won't let himself admitted.
That's awesome.
One of the common fears about pegging is who?
I am afraid that it's just I'm going to get showered and shit,
but that's kind of the price is going to pay two to give them a good pegging.
Another fear is being seen as gay.
Is that a fear of yours?
I mean if somebody accuses me of being gay then I'll just come over their face.
I guess he's been crushing my post.
Devastating it for years and years.
I know.
He's straight.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of,
I'm going to fucking lose my mind if the dogs keep barking.
So do you want to go take care of them and also let me call back instacart.
They'd called.
Did you beat the shit out of the dogs?
I wish I did.
I thought you were going to hit it everybody.
No,
I just told him to shut the fuck up.
Oh my God.
I didn't know what I was saying.
He didn't speak English well.
Fiefs Englishes Amaz bitsy,
not so much,
but it was who was barking?
I couldn't tell because they were done not barking when I went out there.
Oh,
they're the backyard.
No,
they're just in the house to was barking at nothing.
They bark at people.
They know they,
they've work at noises.
They don't fucking bark at real things.
Are we recording right now?
Yeah.
Oh,
I want to,
can I?
Okay.
What do you think so much to talk about this a sidebar.
We,
for those of you writing in,
we resolved bitsy diarrhea problem.
Say thanks for [inaudible] but first can I just talk about this?
We got her a dog.
Burka.
It's like a little thing.
It covers her face.
I'll show you a picture of it and now she can't eat.
It's giving her diarrhea.
So problem solved.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
it's great.
We um,
we put her in her burka,
which goes out back so she can't eat rotten fruit and whatever else it is.
Yeah,
we'll show you.
It looks retarded.
Okay.
So yes,
Nikki Glaser.
Thank you.
It was super fun.
And the instructor was,
remember that Australian lady we had on here that cut the hair out of her ears,
cut her ear out of her hair?
It's a little of that aesthetic.
No,
Sheila.
I think so.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm a bad memory.
I was tired that it wasn't like that.
Yeah,
no,
but she was like,
her name was ruby.
She,
she,
the main thing that I really like respected about her when she was really great
teaching the pegging class.
Yeah.
But she,
I was like,
how did you get into this?
And she was,
you know,
whatever.
Just discovered it.
And then I go,
how often do you do this?
She goes,
I like him.
He young and pretty.
Yeah.
She was like,
like a dude talking about his conquest.
She's like,
yeah,
basically.
Fuck guys on the regular.
It's great.
Yeah.
She's a sturdy lady too.
She off our ad.
You know what I thought was interesting about that class,
which they did an air is we asked like,
should we do two fingers or three fingers and your asshole versus a Dildo first
member?
And she goes,
no,
you may as well go for the dildo cause it's about the same.
Well,
what she was saying,
no,
it was the,
I think it was the opposite.
It was,
hey that looks too big.
You know,
how about something the size of a finger?
And she goes,
well then just use a finger.
Like if you're gonna,
if you want something besides a totally different class,
you know,
sounds like it sounds like.
Yeah.
If you want something the size of a finger,
just use your finger.
Right.
You know,
which makes sense.
Yeah.
Which by the way,
since the class,
nothing's changed.
You still haven't done anything.
No fingers,
no toys,
nothing.
I still got this totally fucking just open,
kind of hanging out their ass hole,
waiting for something to come in.
Birthday passed.
It was my birthday.
Nothing.
Well I thought you were going to get your anus waxed before I did any.
I never,
I never suggested I was going to do that.
No,
you've been talking about what it was completely after that.
That was after that.
After that conversation you're acting like that was part of no,
it was totally separate from that.
I was talking about my wiping and that I want a clean asshole again.
Yeah,
but what makes you think I want to get in there?
If it's covered in mud all.
It's not about you.
It's muddy.
It's smelly.
By the way.
Your birthday.
Happy Smurf Day.
Thanks.
What was really nice?
I really appreciated this.
We were laying in bed and you lifted your legs.
You're on your back and you lifted your two legs up like a baby diaper change
and then he farted and you were wearing nothing but boxers.
You rent one and then you rolled over and you go,
so what's up?
Am I going to throw you the day to day or what?
I don't sit on this d.
No,
I didn't go.
Really?
You're going to,
after you farted on me.
I said,
how about a blow job,
right.
Do you think now is the appropriate time to ask for something like that?
Yeah,
because there was no fart in there anymore.
It was gone now,
so now you know I'm not going to fart during a Bj because,
but why the theatrical?
I mean if you wanted me to touch her d,
why the theatrical of pulling your legs behind your ears in your boxer shorts
like you,
you went out of your way to be disgusting.
I wasn't trying to be disgusting.
I was trying to,
no,
I was trying to be comical about it.
Entertaining.
I didn't want you to just hear a boring fart like,
oh,
I hear this all the time.
I'm trying to give you something cool to listen to.
Can we talk about the fight I had yesterday on the couch?
Which one?
The one that you were like,
that really smells like poison because we had to mommy.
Yeah.
It's very rich.
It's very,
it's very heavy.
I got the truffle Burger,
which makes a bad smell on the way out apparently.
And the fries.
I did a heavy bag workout after we had those.
Oh my God.
You want to throw up?
No,
because it had already settled,
but it really made the brown come out.
Really?
Oh yeah,
man.
It was the Umami Burger
that made the brown or the heavy bag.
It was the fitness plus the food.
But the combination,
I think of a rich burger and a pretty intense cardio workout.
You're going to brown every time.
It was just no way around it.
Did you?
So which bathroom did you use?
Did you use a bad day?
Of course.
I really prefer the downstairs.
The day it's warmer and stronger.
I need to,
what?
Can we get warm water upstairs?
I don't know.
And I know cold stream.
It's not the same.
It's a fucking firehose downstairs too.
It's so strong.
My asshole hurts.
I know.
I kinda like it.
And it's like the seats super warm.
Now I'm telling you,
I've gone,
I've even incorporate a little bit of your action.
I've got even gone.
Shit the button,
you know like yeah,
that's what I did.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
Are you saying that you don't shit and then go straight to washing?
Sometimes I go wipe one wipe first.
Why is it good?
Some of the general mud out,
but you're crazy.
I think you're wasting toilet paper at this point.
You need to go straight to water to hose.
Yeah.
And then it takes it off like paint,
you know,
he really didn't have the power wash.
Cold water doesn't work the same.
It's gotta be out.
Not the same.
I know how really the key top dog taught me that.
A lot of people were really into his phone call last week.
Big feedback on that.
It was really good.
It was,
it was ah,
the magic that he shot on his comforter bedspread embeds.
Right.
And got a little squirt on the best bread.
You know,
I listened to that call again.
Yeah.
And the part that really gets me is that he wasn't,
he didn't intend on washing it like he wouldn't have if he were living alone.
That's the part that if you go old school,
and I mean episode,
I couldn't even tell you the episode,
but it's where my dad sharded when we were together.
Yeah.
It was the uh,
oh,
in Maine and Maine and he shat five feet too far.
Oh,
was yesterday.
I didn't make it and I was,
you know,
it was so ugly.
I had to go and you know,
I misread the sign and the hotel and they had to go down the stairs and I,
I was squeezed squeezing the cheeks going down the stairs.
Yeah.
And then went into one of these places,
you know,
where the,
you're rushing,
but it's one of these handicap stalls.
It's an extra five feet before you get to them.
Yeah.
And is five feet too far,
five feet too far
that whenever the episode,
whatever episode that was,
he shit.
And he walked,
you know,
I was in the bathroom in the hotel where we were sharing a hotel room,
Tommy,
you done in there and like,
I'm taking a shit.
What are you,
what are you fucking asking me if like he kept knocking and he goes,
yeah,
I shit my pants.
And I was laughing so hard and he told me what happened and then we're going to
go out,
we're going to go out to a movie or something and I go,
what are you doing with those pants?
And he's like putting them on and they go,
you just shitting them?
And he goes,
oh,
I shit in the underwear.
Oh man,
I go,
but isn't there probably some on the pants.
He goes,
it's just a little bit of shit and I go,
you can't fucking wear those.
So growth,
he wanted to wear them out.
Oh
it's so gross.
Yeah.
There's a lot of,
I have a lot of just shit clips from him.
Have
oil in them already.
Okay.
So this is,
is that the end of the day they were born,
they would burn it.
They would take every game every day and they wouldn't everybody shit together.
He had multiple,
he's talking about shitting in the Shit and Vietnam in the burn.
Yeah,
they're shit.
it was like a Porta potty.
Right,
right.
And then you would,
you would,
you would burn it.
Okay.
And that's why they call it bean and did shit.
Right.
Cause right.
Did you guys like,
would you try to shit in similar places?
Like if I took a shit here,
when you come by the same area or are you just share wherever you want to?
Shit.
Wow.
You would grab the boy.
She just find it.
What you do is you dig a hole with your entrenching tool,
which is a military term for shovel.
And remember when you're in the kind of food you're eating and because you're
burning up so many calories,
the the size of poops we had were about what a dog does.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Because isn't the military food designed them to block you up to like Mras now
they say are designed to be like,
cause he experts we meet once a day.
Why do I talk?
Do you hate luxury yourself?
So stupid.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah,
it's horrible.
Oh,
I got a bunch of those.
But um,
he uh,
yeah,
just a little bit of shit that's in there somewhere in that episode when an
animal,
he's an animal.
I can now I see all these bottles.
Just say top top,
top dog.
Like so old plan is here.
Hey Buddy.
Call.
I don't know what this is about even.
Hello Tommy?
Yeah.
Hey Buddy,
how you doing?
What's up man?
Just chilling right now.
I'm just chillin.
Chillin.
Okay.
Uh,
uh,
I haven't talked to you a little bit of your dental work.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Everything's going good,
you know,
good and uh,
been been feeling pretty good.
You know,
your little traveling,
get the Orlando airport the other day.
Uh,
the infamous Orlando Airport.
Yeah.
I was in there a head to catch a flight to Memphis and a head.
Now the turtle,
all of a sudden I felt one coming on.
I needed to,
I needed to get in there and take it down the Pronto,
so I'll go into one of those,
you know,
terminal air,
men's rooms.
Yeah.
And every stall is full except the handicapped stall again.
Really sorry.
So I charge in there,
you know,
really came on strong.
Uh,
sat down,
drop my load immediately and then I looked in and there was only enough toilet
paper for one wipe and this wasn't a single wipe down,
I'm assuming.
Oh,
this was Elise.
This is probably a five,
five,
maybe six.
Wiper.
Okay.
Is it,
would you classify it as like a glider or um,
you know,
a blast or something like that?
Or is it just something,
I wasn't a last year,
but it was,
um,
in between,
a slider and a sloppy Joe.
Hey,
will you turn the TV down in the background?
Yep.
Okay.
And so,
uh,
yeah,
all of a sudden I look over it and normally,
you know,
as I've told you before,
when you're traveling,
you got to check to make sure this bay,
I didn't,
I had no choice in the matter.
You didn't do your Rico.
Yeah,
I'm actually super curious.
Right.
Because I totally forget this call of how he cleaned this up.
I don't know how I cleaned this up,
whether he took his socks off or what do a recon because I had to go and there
was no other stalls available.
So you know,
it was either there or on the floor.
Okay.
So,
right.
So what I did was all of a sudden I noticed that they have those,
you know,
totally papers covers that people use the toilet seat cover totally sick.
I never used them personally.
But um,
always just sit on the seat.
Yeah,
I did yellow.
Sure.
Just set up,
see the too much trouble to use those things.
Yeah.
And then you position them wrong.
He ended up hitting him,
you know what I mean?
And then you create a bigger mess.
So I don't use them,
but what I found out,
you can take those chairman little pieces in you that it started paper route or
he is
so that's that and use that.
Like you said it like a detective solving a case.
Right.
He's a brown lock right.
Tactic.
I've done that.
You were at the house with her when she was there,
but I've done that too.
Haven't you ever used the,
that is a a 12 paper.
That's why let's take cover.
I have many occasions.
Many occasions.
Yeah.
Cause a lot of times the ladies room,
there's no tp in the ladies room,
no TV because women have to wipe it every time.
Number two,
so.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Sometimes you're out a lot.
That makes sense though.
Yeah.
You can use that to wipe.
Okay.
Ha.
Ah Ha ha.
Hey Dad,
what a genius.
Hey Buddy,
how you doing?
Good.
How are you?
A pretty good,
pretty good.
Yeah.
No.
What's a,
what's going on?
Well,
just got a,
my new favorite lunch.
She now is this seafood
Cobb salad?
Fucking no,
I don't see,
is that the club he goes to?
I don't know where it was.
The same place every day.
He goes yeah.
And the dual lane McDonald's.
I remember he was not a fan of dual lane McDonald school.
Yeah.
But he still loves Mcdonald's coffee,
right?
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Yup.
There you go.
So it was your birthday this week.
It was my smurf day.
Um,
by the way,
thanks for putting it out there to the,
um,
to the general public on Twitter.
Uh,
get,
tell Tom,
how old do you think he is?
I had quite a range.
Uh,
you'll never believe this,
but nobody actually guests the actual age.
Everyone Kelly older.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So we gently older.
Yeah.
So I had everything from,
I think the youngest age I thought I saw was a happy 42nd birthday.
And all the way up to,
I saw a lot of,
uh,
hey,
next year's the big five.
Oh,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah.
All the way to 58 and 60.
But yes.
Yes.
You are a young 60 though.
I think a young 60 years.
You want to tell people what your actual ages or do you want to leave it a
mystery?
Oh,
I'll tell them.
Yeah,
I'd,
I'd now officially 37 years old.
I remember that flies by man.
37 years of your life.
Yeah.
And you can't believe it.
Like you hear it doesn't even sound right.
Do you feel like you're going to die soon?
Physically?
Yes.
Yeah.
I do feel like I'm going to die.
You really feel like you're falling apart.
Is that happening for you yet?
No.
I mean,
um,
this,
oh my God,
put them on.
Okay,
wait,
but do this first.
Look at the camera normal so that they see what your eyeballs look like.
Yeah.
And then put them on.
Now
it magnifies your eyes.
You look like my Nana.
This is what my grandma used to.
Yeah.
Big Eyes.
Other kind of cool though.
I liked the frames.
I like them.
They just,
they make your eyes look bigger while they make the words look bigger.
And that's why I like him.
He's you wait,
you can't,
she,
when you're aware of him,
did you get those at the rite aid or are those three?
I'll get the fuck outta here.
These were a fortune glasses are really expensive cheeses.
I know you don't want to,
you don't want to fuck those up and cost a fortune thing.
No,
but my parents just would go to rite aid and buy the rite aid ones.
I Louie them to read now and look at computer basically.
Yeah.
And you're so old,
man,
doc.
So fucking bad.
Well,
I had the,
uh,
I had the vision test a year ago and they were like,
Nah,
I mean you could get them but you don't need them.
And I was like,
okay,
did,
uh,
you know,
a year later I went for the followup test and they were like,
absolutely need them now because of how poorly I was doing and I didn't bring
them when I renewed my driver's license and they go,
you know the shit that I've done for years where she's like,
look up at that chart.
I okay.
And she goes to close one eye.
All right,
read line for,
and I go a c D v seven and she goes seven,
seven.
And I go,
yeah.
And I took my hand down and it was a tea.
Oh my gosh.
And she goes,
hold on,
read the,
and then she was,
now you just look with both eyes,
go look in this thing.
She made me go to something else and I was reading it like,
um,
I dunno if this is gonna fly right now.
I,
you know I,
I was in like in a little bit of a panic.
What if I fail the vision test without these horse and I just up your whole
world.
Oh,
your vision,
what,
what happens to you?
The dinner.
I know cause I closed one,
I was reading through a little box,
you know,
with that was backlit.
Ah.
And I,
I could see them,
but then there was one that I couldn't really see and I go,
uh,
five s cause I,
I was about to say a number again.
I go s s s and she was like,
okay,
you had me worried for a second and I'm like,
you fucking had me worried for a second.
Yeah.
So now I know that I got to bring these more often or you got to bring him
everywhere.
Yes.
Maybe you have a pair that you just leave in the car.
I'm going to get a second
for driving.
Yeah.
Do you need,
is that for driving too?
You need them?
They said,
um,
I mean like,
you know,
I see fine looking around,
whatever,
but they said if you're driving for a long time you might want to bust them out.
I know fucking 70 going down and drive as I drive long and I don't see so good.
Yeah,
man.
And I'm going to be 40 in June.
Whole Lee.
I know,
I know.
It's really crazy.
What can I tell you something though?
I'm not as devastated.
I think turning 30 was more horrible for me than then the idea of 40 because
I'm,
I've accepted the fact that I'm an older person now.
I think 30 is when yeah,
it once you commit,
you can't quit.
When then once you grab his Tsp,
someone wraps a rubber band around his mouth.
Hey,
make sure that mouth is closed.
I'm really scared because I'm afraid that a crock.
So embarrassed.
How did you do once you commit,
you can't quit
the team.
I'm really scared because
look at me.
I'm fucking hot.
I'm a teenager.
Look at,
I'm a baby.
Oh my gosh.
Can you believe how young like look out.
I was a baby doing that,
so I'll probably do later.
I'll bang you and then we'll turn it off.
Thanks video.
I'm going to throw up.
I'm afraid that I now I was going to jump out of the water and try it.
Bye.
Oh my God.
Oh,
fucking.
Why are you showing me this?
I was so depressed.
All right.
Is that I still had under eye bags.
Okay.
What's your name up?
That's so great.
Shane was here couple weeks ago.
He was,
you know what guys?
He's on Twitter too.
Why don't you go ahead and hit him up?
He loves talking about road rules,
African road rules,
questions he likes.
Uh,
let me give me as he remembers every detail of every challenge.
I know it's so weird.
Asked me about this challenge.
Asked me about that at Shane.
E m.
C.
B.
So Shane Mcbride,
but s h a.
Y n.
E.
M.
CB.
Hit him up on Twitter.
Guys loves interactions on Twitter.
Loves asking,
ask him all kinds of questions about road rules.
Yeah,
never forget.
Thanks for showing that,
Tom.
That was really cool of you.
Uh,
well to show my pass like that,
I really,
first of all,
you look amazing,
right?
You do.
I look like a child.
It's kind of crazy how little you look like a piece of a s.
S thanks.
Yeah.
And that's all I could think about when I saw that clip of you.
I can only think of this real quick.
Yes.
Have you ever had the taste of Chinese seaman?
No worries.
That haircut,
by the way.
I had actually that I love
the haircut.
That road rules haircut you do?
Yes.
And what did it make?
What it tastes like?
Soy Sauce.
Yeah.
Salty flavoring.
I do.
I love the salty flavoring and understand we'll cook every time you swallow.
Chinese soy sauce,
seaman,
seaman.
There's billions and billions of sea monkeys floating and swimming in your
stomach is so sassy.
Monkeys.
Got You.
Would you like some today?
I would love to them.
Would you like to compare and contrast white boy seaman?
Oh yeah.
To try to match.
Yeah,
that would be wonderful.
I like nothing better.
Back to the road rules,
haircut,
that haircut.
I got more emails limit.
Yeah.
Her letters about that haircut back in the day.
You love my road rules here.
You're always telling me that you want me to get my haircut.
I love road rules here.
Can I tell you the problem with doing that at 40 I just look like a mom.
A mom can.
You can do that at 20 and you look cool.
Yeah.
40 you look like you hate your husband.
And I go for a mom because
mom's here.
You're an official mom.
Now I have to wear it.
The Coo lots.
Those jorts that the moms wear some sandals.
I got to cut my hair short.
That A,
that low maintenance cut for moms saves a lot of time.
It's a time saver.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anyway,
it says that John and Kate plus eight Oh,
she hated him.
That's why she did that.
That is a don't touch my post haircut for sure.
Stay the fuck away from my crutch.
Yeah.
So we went to,
I took you to get Japanese massage.
Yeah.
Which was amazing.
And this was,
I mean this was a,
a a high
end spa.
Yeah.
It wasn't just like,
oh,
there's a couple of,
you know,
Japanese people in this strip mall.
This was like a,
a really high end spa was a nice birthday treat.
Yeah.
So where they make you wear like Kimono,
robes and stuff,
which was super fun.
And then there's a,
it's called a photo,
a photo of bath and we walk like her would bath.
That's,
yeah.
It's like 150 degrees.
It feels awesome and the temperature never drops.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I don't really,
really crazy.
Anyway,
we were at,
at the bathtub and I was like boom,
they're getting away with it.
We should explain this first.
Okay,
go ahead.
We settle in.
It's a whole like welcoming experience where they sit you down and you put on
your,
your Komono,
the massage,
your feet.
I fell asleep during it.
It was,
that part was so good.
Yeah.
And you liked the level of some of subservience there.
I love it.
A lot of bowing,
a lot of May I enter sir,
May I?
It's just everything.
Okay Sir.
I love it.
They're head's always lower than yours.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
You liked that people know their place and then,
um,
we did the massage,
which was excellent.
And then they go,
uh,
yeah,
the bath tubs over there.
It's in the same room.
You know,
you first said you go,
now you have a bath.
And I thought because it's just a single tub that it was just for me cause I
didn't understand that.
So I go,
okay.
Yeah.
And then I go and then the lady comes and she washes you.
She washes your cock and balls.
Yeah.
And the look on your face.
You were so excited.
You're like,
what?
Really?
Like yeah,
it's your special day.
Yeah.
Like this is an expensive Jack Shack.
You said the,
the Lady's gonna wash your,
your cock and balls and I know what yeah.
And then,
and you go,
yeah.
You said yes,
you go,
yeah.
And I go,
really?
And you got no,
what if that was part of the package?
She's like,
okay,
no.
Why should your Cutco and your,
and I really,
honestly,
I never,
when you said that,
didn't think like,
hey,
this lady's going to get you off in here.
I thought you meant like this is such an authentic,
traditional old,
what they do in the whole country was like an actual bathing experience.
And I was like,
no fucking shit.
Yeah.
I thought someone's going to come with a sponge and just cleaned me off
everywhere.
Right.
And I was like,
wow.
Then you gotta know
you gotta wash your own cock and balls.
Yeah.
It's kind of neat.
They let you shower and sit in a bathtub together and they,
it's the very rare,
most places they think you're going to have sex.
They don't let men and women be naked together in the same room.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like I never been to a spa where they're like,
yes,
you're an adult.
Yeah.
Surely you can handle this responsibility of being nude.
Sure.
Together.
Well,
you did your duty before that come everywhere.
Yeah,
I didn't mind.
Yeah.
After you farted,
after I farted,
you did what?
You did what you do and then you know
I want like weekend.
What you say?
You didn't hear that?
No.
Here we go.
Oh,
whoa.
Oh Wow.
I'm a white boy.
Come.
What a job
tastes like.
Salami.
Yeah,
definitely Salami.
My favorite is always the dumb girl.
Nervous the point.
Oh girl,
laugh.
[inaudible] has that
so damaged.
Let me Daddy.
This is like kind of like the calm gov product that we tried to pitch the shark
tank because this girl is comparing all the different races,
you know?
Right.
I feel like shark tank.
Nice white boy,
please.
You have to laugh after every sentence and you're an important point.
Oh yeah,
I see
hot dogs.
Oh Gosh.
So gross.
I just sent you an email.
I forgot to send it to you before.
There's some songs.
I want you to hear the songs that this guy just sent it to.
Uh,
should I say or email my email,
which would account [inaudible] dot com.
Okay.
Anyway,
well,
I think about doing it like that was my job swallowing calm.
Can you think of anything worse in life?
I would rather bathed in the Japanese.
If Hutto Beth,
every stranger in la,
give them a bath.
I'd rather sponge bath strangers than Blue Lake.
Suck their genes there.
Gene juice.
Oh.
Oh
my God.
They're making
lacking.
Oh God.
Yeah.
They're making soy sauce.
Barf done.
I'm not done.
Let's see what else.
I think that was like,
fuck I soup or something.
Wow.
She know how to say that Shit.
Tom,
could I super soft bank.
Mayo and noodles don't mix.
He's a white boy.
No,
it was crazy as it.
She's the worst it,
there's so many loads.
Being dry.
Yours tastes like dessert.
One year's worth and it's,
I seen Kim.
Yay.
ECON tells me z.
You See
Mimi?
What's he saying?
You're retired.
He retired.
He said that.
Hmm
is said,
I got here with all my kids.
I got here,
I came with all my kids.
You know,
like my kids are in your mouth basically that so fucking gross.
God,
why does he have to personalize it like that?
No,
I'm going to throw up.
Can we stop listening to them?
It's almost over.
It's freedom.
May Have side of it
to America.
Yeah.
That was definitely,
definitely three.
Hollis and Dorothy has all the way.
Okay.
Oh Jeez.
Excellent.
It's really good though.
That was sewn rice day.
Dude.
That's a worst job in the world.
I would rather dig ditches and pick up garbage in the streets for the rest of my
life and do what that woman did in that one clip.
Seriously,
seriously,
dig ditches.
I'd rather pick up at garbage all day,
every day by the freeway.
Really?
Yup.
And do that one scene
there.
Anything worse?
I mean know if you're,
if you're asking me,
I would definitely take those ditches to for the rest of my day,
every day,
90 years old and digging ditches and I'm happy about it.
[inaudible] Shit.
I don't have to blow these eight guys.
Compare.
There's nuts.
Yeah.
Ha.
So what are these songs just play and you're going to look at it.
You don't really have it.
These are submitted by fans.
Yes.
Okay.
Faggot.
No,
I lied.
You right.
The next one.
That's a song.
I know what you're doing.
Next one's definitely a song.
God.
No,
it's just play it.
If there's one thing I know in this world,
it's dicks and Coxson balls.
What are you doing?
Blue man?
Help me get,
you know,
play the next one.
The next one's a song for real.
It doesn't want to do not mind being in something where the word nigger is you
and that song.
No
planning.
10 want to keep playing this game.
Just play the next one that I had.
Blue Band.
I'm the president of the Dixon.
I'm the president of the Dixie Song Faggot.
Wow,
you're so you're so full of hate.
I had no idea.
You are so hateful.
Finally got sick of being the one that gets caught all the time,
Huh?
Yeah.
Gotcha.
You're such a Shit Turd.
He brought up the road rules.
If there's one thing I know in this world,
it's dicks and Cox and balls.
It's true.
First of all,
blue ban brought up road rules on his own.
Sure he did.
Sure.
He said he just brought that look.
Yeah,
but he submits all the potential clips and then you choose this time.
Well,
I mean it was a good choice and you're the worst.
Is that it?
Is there one more sound?
No,
that's it.
Speaking of Fuck Boys,
you know we've been getting these horse shit emails about how fuck boy isn't
about gay gay things and you guys come on,
grow up.
Everybody knows it is.
First of all,
let's look at the urban dictionary.
I'm going to look it up for you right now.
Listen,
listen.
Urban Dictionary fuckboy a person who is a weak ass pussy.
That ain't about shit.
Look at this.
Weak as fuck.
Boy.
Sounds pretty clear to me.
That was very pretty clear to me too.
Some people are like,
no,
it means player.
No,
no.
It means a person who was a weak ass pussy.
That ain't about shit.
Look at that weak ass.
Fuck Blake's urban dictionary.
That's true.
I didn't make that shit up.
Anyway.
Pro,
you know,
hot debate solved.
Absolutely.
Um,
I also want to point out to saying that road rules club man,
80 years old now I want to point out to our faith fans of the show that I do now
have my DJ equipment.
I'm going to be hooking it up in the garage.
Um,
I kept it out of the nursery so we found that compromise,
but I should be spinning pretty soon.
I was in Vegas this weekend.
I got to tell you this,
I found out.
Yeah,
I did a private on Thursday.
Um,
at encore.
That sounds like when you're like,
I did a private,
it sounds like you're saying I'm a Dick and ball expert.
I am a ticking box,
but I did.
I did a private,
if there's one thing I know in this world,
it's dicks and Cox and ball and I'm the president of the Dixon,
you know,
and that's what they hire you for your private private private event.
It was a corporate event.
There's are always dicey.
You never know how it's going to go.
But ended up being,
it was with a bunch of um,
uh,
rich,
rich as Fuck Texts and oiled people on linkedin.
We all met on Linkedin and they hired me to do a standup show.
They were,
a lot of them were amp for the show,
but I got to say it,
they still,
they treated me right.
I had a good time.
I got to give a shout out to half jap Ricky what,
who have jap Ricky and Kurd.
So both of them,
uh,
kind of organized everything and um,
yeah,
we,
you know,
we did the show full charge came with me.
Um,
there was,
there was a lot of memorable moments.
It was just kind of felt like a high end bar show,
you know,
like it was like,
uh,
yeah,
Ph do's where you're like yelling shit.
A Guy I thought almost died,
literally almost died in the audience and he might be dead now.
He,
um,
cause there were a couple of guys that were passed out in the like in the seat.
So you saw ha just completely out.
And one dude,
I was like,
hey,
maybe check his pulse because it was old.
And he was like leaning forward.
Like that kind of made,
he made some gesture and then later I go,
that guy really looks dead now.
And they,
someone tapped him and he caught his breath.
But it was like,
it went from being funny,
the scary cause you went
like that and I was like,
um,
you all right.
And when I said,
are you all right?
He went thumbs down.
Oh my God.
And I go,
uh,
and then the security came over and tried to escort him out and he wouldn't
leave.
So in the end,
he,
um,
after the show he still had help leaving the room and then they go,
oh,
he ate shit and broke his nose on the way to his room and fell and broke his
nose.
He 37 years old.
No,
he was 137 years old.
He was really old.
So he was just hammered.
Well,
no,
he was old hammered and they said,
uh,
I know he had,
they said he had sleep apnea.
No boy,
you could see when he caught his breath,
that's what,
what happens to people.
Like they catch their breath.
That's really dangerous that that guy's going to sleep right now in his room.
Um,
but I'd like to know if he's dead so I can add it to my bio.
That's a good point.
Could you say if you were a hacky comic,
you can be like,
I killed the show literally.
Or if you're not hacky,
just kind kill confirmed kill would be a great name for a fucking special.
Right.
And then you could be in sniper gear on the cover.
On the box cover.
Yeah.
But at the end of your gun is a microphone.
I liked that.
But then do you have the caution tape over your mouth too?
Like,
well you have caution tape as where they put black stripes under your eyes.
Caution car.
Yeah.
And what's your comedy shirt?
Are you wearing a comedy shirt?
I'm wearing the flame shirt with flames on it.
Yeah,
definitely Dj Dad mouth for a couple couple of comics I saw had those back in
the day where I would be like,
of course.
So up and that was their shirt.
You know,
it's a show comedy shorts.
Some people have comedy shirts.
Yeah.
And then you learn all shirts or comedy shirts,
shirt.
Do just wear any shirt.
Speaking of uh,
comedy shirts and attire.
Some really neat comments on my Instagram,
uh,
regarding my art teacher jacket.
Then you,
you can call it the art jacket.
Let me,
let me pull up some great ones from our listeners.
So funny dude.
I absolutely love when people,
hey,
Hey Hitler,
this is on Instagram.
There's so much Hitler on my Instagram.
Hey Taylor.
I disagree with Tom and most of these comments,
not an art teacher jacket.
Classy.
Well dressed,
high and tight fashionista.
Sorry for big words,
but you know,
you know you mean all the real mommy's?
No,
this butthole is on fleek.
Your art skills are high and tight,
mom.
No.
What I'm saying?
Can you grade my work?
Mrs P
is that my mom or an art teacher?
Macaulay Culkin told me to pray.
Told me in prayer that we should start treating your coat like it was famous.
Oh,
we also got a comment from your friend who is an art teacher who said she was
deeply offended.
Yeah.
She's like,
what guys?
Come on.
I love this one.
Where are we supposed to read the chapter on Rembrandt or on neoclassicism this
weekend?
I was plenty,
so thank you guys for chiming in on that.
Everyone agreed.
It's absolutely an art teacher jacket.
Yeah,
I guess.
I think I'm still going to wear it.
I don't give a shit to a class.
Are you going to wear it to do shows
whenever teacher Jane Pauley by
you really did get this stuff.
I know,
I know you have your table set up,
you have everything ready to go.
Ready to go,
man.
I just got to hook some things up there.
I actually got a computer cause I can't,
I don't have any room left on this computer,
so I've got a computer to,
you know,
spin stuff like that.
Do get,
Oh this is,
what am I to tell you?
This will make you shit your fucking pants.
So I'm hanging out at the encore.
I'm talking to,
to the entertainment director and encore beach club is basically all the vague,
you know,
Vegas is just designed to make money and you make it and a lot of different
ways.
Obviously there's gambling,
there's dining,
right?
Um,
but for the daytime and for uh,
the in shape crowd,
the whole thing is to go there.
Yeah,
yeah.
The people,
it's so true.
People that are fucking young and hot,
they go to Vegas and they go to the kind of the
pardon.
Yes,
that
is is,
it's 140 degrees outside.
They stand outside.
There's,
there's mist spray and then there's a Dj spinning and,
and they bring in the top top people,
right?
Yeah.
Would get a Calvin Harris.
I don't know.
So I go to those guys.
What kind of money to those Djs make?
And they were like,
dude,
they have,
I won't give out cause I don't want to,
but they have two prices.
How do they have two prices while they have the uh,
the premixed set where they press play or the live set where they'll play a lot
more.
Yeah.
And he goes,
and a lot of,
you know,
the pre mixed set is,
all I can say is this,
it's well,
well into six figures and it's for a two hour set and that's press play.
That's,
he shows up,
he sets up his shit and there's a lot of ladies,
right?
Press play and then it's premium stand there and they just go,
Yup,
Yup.
That's all you have to do.
If you want to pay even more,
you get them doing it in real time to the job that they're supposed to be doing
and they get paid how much more to actually do the job even more into six
figures and standup comedy by the way,
is so fucking hard and it takes a decade to get decent at and we don't get paid
nearly as much.
Finally that I actually was so far cad uninformed with like what these guys
play.
I was like,
wait a minute.
So what are they play though as the,
I was asking because I,
I honestly didn't know.
The djs that I know are hip hop Djs,
right?
So I know who they are and the kind of music is played,
but I go,
what,
what kind of music is played by one of these guys?
And he goes,
oh,
it's music.
You know,
so it's like Rihanna or no fucking Taylor swift.
But then it's his remix of that.
And so they're actually playing songs,
you know,
just a remix.
And for that they're commanding that kind of money.
Absurd.
It's not even like their own music song.
It's just yeah they're playing someone else's shit.
So that would be like you going to a comedy club doing like I'm doing Carlin's
tonight guys and you do someone else's jokes but you do like your wacky
impression of him or you record yourself doing someone else's jokes and just
push play in front of an audience.
And they were like half a million.
Give it to us.
That even acceptable to do a prerecorded.
Um,
that's fucking crazy.
So I read this article,
my friend Eric sent me about these girls who for an art project decided to
become fake Dj's.
So what this girl never deejayed in her life but she took like a cursory lesson
so she knew how to do it and basically what she paired up with her cute friend,
these two cute girls,
cause that's like the cool thing to do to women are better than one and they
would use songs that everybody knew.
So she's like basically that audience that loves his DJ stuff is a commodity,
like a commodified audience or whatever.
They only like shit that they know.
Like,
I don't give a fuck about actual music.
Right.
It's just like,
is this familiar gay?
Yeah.
And she's like,
we put together the hackiest set list and within three weeks all the other djs
hated them by the way.
And the Dj community were like,
what the fuck is this?
Like it's so formulaic,
like it's too hot chicks spending shit that everybody knows.
And they're like,
exactly.
That's why this culture sucks so bad.
And within three weeks they had major gigs.
They were like one of the most popular whatever Dj acts at the time.
Yeah.
I'll send you the link to this article.
What's her tits?
Started deejaying Paris Hilton.
I know.
And it'd be fun.
And she was,
you know,
the worst human being.
She was probably getting six figures to do that.
Easy.
Yeah.
But she gets money to just show up at your party.
Sure.
To show up at a bar and be like,
I'm here guys.
Like is there anything worse?
And culture,
fucking God,
that is the worst
mail from a fan.
What?
Sometime Kachina little baby jeans too.
Oh,
here is the dubstep drop.
My two sons and I made with garage band the other day.
Hope you liked the track and went to get us signed to your label before Cain or
drag it through us.
Um,
okay.
Kids are three and six and my old is 40 fucking one.
No Dad mouth though.
I brushed twice a day with my Sonicare toothbrush and floss at least once every
two days.
That's about everything for now.
First time caller,
long time listener.
Love the show and love you like my favorite pair of jeans.
Let's see what he marries.
Time long time for us.
Long time.
First Time
afraid.
Yeah.
Good job.
You're saying.
Yeah,
so this guy made this with his two small children and it sounds identical to the
horse shit that passes for hundreds of thousands of dollars.
Pretty much.
I liked that was good.
I liked it too.
Yeah.
Wow Dude.
You're going to make a killing as a DJ.
That'd be so funny.
If you ended up making just millions as a DJ,
hilarious comedian and you stopped doing comedy.
People are like,
no,
but her Thompson girl,
the Dj,
even better.
I do's Carmen's black.
It was Dan.
It was sex been I need to get a Netflix special spinning.
That'd be great.
Just so boring to watch
turning knobs and shit.
Uh,
yeah.
It's also a very European thing though,
Dude.
My tribe I love that.
Loves that Shit that
Oh yeah.
I remember there was a German girl who,
uh,
I worked with when I had a day job and she was like,
why nobody here likes house music,
like houses the best.
Nobody likes to go dancing.
I was like,
I dunno.
Wack wack job.
But uh,
you're in the fucking us of a now.
Her Dad,
we listened to Bruce Springsteen here.
It's your boss all day or day.
Do you want to do what you do?
You don't do it,
but a,
we don't do that.
Dance in your shit here.
Okay.
Oh my fucking cut.
Oh Shit.
Like,
like cut.
That's her.
Somebody barked at.
Yeah,
that was perfect timing.
Yeah.
So my cat,
my cat and my cat,
by the way.
Thanks for all the emails letting me know that Linkedin is actually helpful.
A lot of that.
A lot of liquidity.
Yeah,
I get it.
I know it's a professional website guys.
Yeah.
They were like,
linkedin actually is help people have found jobs on linkedin.
Sure.
Money on Linkedin.
Of course,
you know,
if you're a fucking dog trainer,
Dennis helpful then it's a,
it's good.
Helps you out.
I'm a fucking dog trainer.
Why are people asking to Comedians to join linkedin?
Like my dad keeps sending us these requests and I'm like,
dude,
do you really Tom and I don't have a profession.
Just like there's,
there's nothing to offer a Lincoln Shit jokes.
It's not talking about wiping on linkedin.
Yeah,
it's not for,
it's not for you motherfucker.
You say for you man.
This is too advanced.
Okay,
Kai.
Um,
farts.
Speaking of your pops,
have you seen this yet?
Eh,
I love the show.
My strange addiction.
We are in the Berg.
My name is Kyle.
I love the grandmas.
I met this lady in a wine named Karen.
I saw her pictures.
I thought she was absolutely.
I am so looking forward to meet her tonight.
Pictures I saw are pleasers pitchers like photography,
photography and I love looking at pictures.
Allow la La local puck of old ladies.
What's a pitcher?
What do you think his deal is?
What's the deal with old Nana's?
He's Nana puss.
His fucking grandma jerked him off and he was a little baby and he's trying to
get back in there.
That's what I think you're right.
Yeah.
Something weird happened with no of course.
Of course.
Lips are really red,
younger.
Her mouth.
She's got that mom was a bit nerve wracking
because
she's younger than I am.
I've got butterflies in my tummy.
Looks like you got butterflies in your tummy and you've got rodents in your
mouth cause those are rotten.
Who talks like that one?
Butterflies in my tummy.
That's a big one.
That's a cap and then she shouldn't see cause I had the same thing this is going
to take,
you got to match them.
You can't just do one front tooth right here.
It's real brown can fix.
You know you can just bond that shit.
This is tough to fix.
This is what I'm going to look like when those eye bags,
well we're going to fuck and how do you fix that?
Can you get dry bags removed for sure.
Going to the knife.
We live in fucking line.
Of course.
I'm going to do that later.
Yeah.
Can I tell you what?
She doesn't look that bad if she fixed.
I don't think she looks bad at all,
but I think her mouth is horrendous.
What does it smell like?
It smells like fucking farts,
man.
It smells terrible.
I've got better flight flies in my current right now in my diaper.
It hasn't happened in so long.
Such a chunk.
She looks sexy as hell,
but long climb in Paris.
I thought,
wow,
it's so great to finally meet you
and pictures looking at all your pictures and they're real pretty.
Anything aside.
She's crazier than cat shit.
This checks in our fucking gears to crazy.
Oh,
that's so sweet of you.
Just say that.
I keep telling you.
Why did you respond?
Like how do we end up there?
I look at like all of these celebrity women that are going out with younger men
and I thought,
well,
you know,
maybe I should try it.
You seem to be intelligent,
although I'm not going to say that I necessarily decided to come out with you
because of your mind
and to be able to feel like this again.
You knew just oh Ah,
Ooh,
happen next.
But it will be brand new.
What's going to happen next is your oral decay is going to lead to a heart
issue.
Yeah.
For it is.
So you've done a lot of traveling and rung.
I'm going to pause for a second.
Where did this full taker where like Mozzarella sticks or on the year they had
Denny's.
I Dunno.
It's disgusting somewhere.
Nice Dude.
Fuck Olive Garden.
So tired babe.
Can I,
can I be good for her that she's,
she's pulling some young tail.
Yeah.
No,
I'm here.
I ain't hating on that.
It's just,
it's,
it's crazy.
She looks crazy and we are more conditioned to seeing old fucking piece of shit.
Thank you.
The wretched ugly dad mouse with the hot young things.
How's Basset Hound?
They look so horrendous.
Beautiful young women.
And you're like,
what?
Yeah,
because of,
you know,
scratch of course.
But she's in it.
She's getting it.
Just because it's good friends.
His Dick.
It's hard with them.
Yes.
There's someone for everyone.
That's the lesson to the story.
You kind of has weird teeth to,
his lips are a little red for my liking on the man.
Yeah.
Would you go with like someone like me cause I'm old enough to be your mother.
Definitely.
Ah,
oh,
oh
no.
You gotta go get that fixed.
You've got to make that linkedin is helpful.
You got to,
you gotta start a go fund me.
Jesus.
Black decay is not cool and that's any age that's not just on acceptable.
Fix your damn teeth.
You don't,
you skip clothes,
you skipped,
you skipped meals at use.
Skip paying your bills and you just get your teeth fucking fixed.
That's what you do when your shit looks like that.
God dammit.
It is so upsetting to her.
Especially because she doesn't need to get those big white,
she doesn't need to get the Steve Harvey's needs to fix the decay on that too.
Then I'd say white and not just look at what shader to,
yeah,
yeah.
I can someone just do this work for her for,
for looks like beetle juice.
Like Michael Keaton.
I got to give up if you want to get a load of me.
Yeah,
it's totally over buddy.
Give me a little kiss.
Totally.
Beetle juice man.
Dang.
Oh well
she's not totally time.
She goes,
get on all fours.
I'm going to have it low desert from the backside.
How do you think I got this to the whole Brown Brown too.
Yeah.
The day was,
Karen was incredible.
She was a 100% my type,
I'm gonna throw up.
I had a wonderful time with and I've had such an amazing time.
I just don't want it to end
throw up a penis is pointing inward right now.
It was so upsetting.
It really,
it's only the tooth.
I don't care about the other stuff.
It's like,
dude,
just fucking get your life.
Get Jar because man,
I'm telling you,
I had to replace my two front teeth every 10 years and we were broke as a joke,
but we put money,
get mama teeth,
you know,
we got,
we had debt from it.
You know?
Yeah.
Because it's that important.
That is how important it is.
I would say there's a lot of things where it's not worth the debt.
People want to do things,
things,
but things on your face,
face,
Brown faces worth debt.
Your face go into debt for your mouth.
Your mouth.
Yeah.
It's so important.
How did she smile?
You know,
when I got my,
my veneers done this time around,
the guy did them,
was this amazing craftsmen.
Yeah,
and he said that people,
people don't smile for years when they have jacked up teeth.
Could you imagine not smiling because you're ashamed of your team?
Clearly she's not,
but other people you know and your muscles and your lips and everything change
over time.
He said that he'd get it takes a while to get used to smiling when you get new
teeth.
I made,
made me almost cry hearing that like that.
People don't smile because of their teeth.
Yeah,
no,
it sucks.
It sucks.
I feel like that woman and this guy would be actually a great match.
I'm going to show you.
Yeah.
Cairo sage or I wasn't looking for trouble on the light rail that night.
The trouble certainly found him and when that fight broke out,
he was ready for it.
With his trusty Katana,
the fight had been going on for about 20 minutes.
She was two on one and none of them saw Cairo stage zero move around behind
them.
To them,
they probably thought I was just moving out in a way,
but I was actually setting up to where their blind spot was.
The sad truth is is that they weren't even
just to pull out a sword.
Keto said you'd all
challenge.
This is about what you saw on the train.
It's folded tempered and it does its job.
Oh,
it says the three men on the train are lucky they ran because I already had a
full,
a full five stage plan ready to take her
a five state.
Looking at,
I love this at the brim of the hat.
He's out of his fucking mind guy is completely crazy.
Those guys in New York City in the 80s the angels where they called and they
would,
they would fight crime on fucking subways and shit.
What would they call that?
The blue angels.
Come on,
man.
Pilots.
I know.
I gotta look it up.
It's killing me.
There's a group of nerds in the 80s and they would be on subways and they'd see
stuff happen and they would fight crime.
That's what this guy does.
This guy though,
there's a lot of fucking basement time in this guy.
Of course.
He's a nerd.
We'll,
we'll let,
okay,
let's let her talk
out and anybody else who got involved just in case.
That's just the way I do things.
There's a little poll sending between him and there and there's him,
him,
him.
If he had gone on me,
I was planning to go in,
completely brought the sword down and then completely cut it out completely gay
cape.
I'm open because my family couldn't handle me.
I had a surprisingly strange affinity.
My family couldn't handle crazy sharp objects,
particularly kitchen knives when I was a kid,
so we traded in the knives from lifetime of studying.
The sword,
the Kitano,
it goes with him everywhere.
Actually carry this because I become a little bit more dangerous than without it
than with it,
so it's more of a restraint mechanism.
Been a safety blanket.
I love this guy.
He just said then he's more dangerous without it.
It's a restraint.
Yeah.
It's keeping him from being as dangerous as he truly
is mind,
but let's be honest,
not it's all in his mind.
Of course.
In his mind it's mine.
He's a superhero dude.
I love it.
Yeah,
he's put,
could you see him dating that older lady?
Yes.
That's the kind of guy that makes sense with like a nice do gooder a crime
fighter.
Please remind me what is the thing that I'm thinking of?
It's not the blue angels.
What are you looking for?
What?
He's these group of nerds and they weren't,
they would wear uniforms and they blegh police New York City.
Okay.
The red,
the blue angels,
something like that.
Fuck.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
My man,
you're too young.
The Guardian Angel,
Guardian Angels.
That guy needs to be a guardian angel.
I think he is.
Yeah,
he is.
I love him.
He's a sword wielding guardian angels.
He just watches too many,
um,
Japan animation shows and then he thinks he's like a Japan summation character.
Really does think he has digital auntie.
I love me some vigilantism wait,
do you think those,
it played the footage of the black guys freaking out?
No,
not really.
You know how black people freak out?
How do they do it?
Mr. Sword?
He got a sword.
They don't do that.
I don't think it would be so composed.
I think that
that's probably more accurate or black
do it.
I don't think it would be like that.
I don't think so.
How would they do it?
How are those black guys say?
Some shit.
If they saw a white kid with a story,
I think,
oh shit is exactly what,
what happened?
Yeah.
I think they would.
It would be like fighting.
We were like,
Shit like that and then he's run out yet Nancy.
Okay.
That sounds like that's people watching a clip.
People on the train right here.
Right.
That's a spectator,
not the actual
shit.
Your pants if you're in a fight and then the guy goes out fucking sword.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Why don't you that guy?
Cause even in his recap to the newspeople,
he was like,
and I was going to go like this and then slice them open like that.
Do was ready to kill people.
Hey,
hey.
Number one.
Good for,
I love it.
I mean look,
I fucking seen people fighting and shit in public school.
There's nothing scarier than a dog pile of people just punching each other.
Good.
Yes.
What a fuck was the sword guy when I was getting my ass kicked in junior high?
What I want to know.
Go ahead.
Good.
We need more guys like him.
Vigilantes,
good guardian angels like taxi driver.
Good.
Tremendous boxer.
Amir Khan who actually he at recently.
I think
I could pull this up.
Is it sugar cones,
cousin
man,
I was,
again,
this is for me.
Just for me.
That was really,
that was rough.
Here's American.
Um,
crazy.
Alex.
Why the fuck make that smaller?
Oh really?
Yeah.
If you want drag.
Okay.
Oh Shit.
This mother fucker got a sword.
Here's Amir Khan.
Recently,
right here.
What crazy looks like.
Shut up.
Yeah.
So crazy.
Looks at his gym and Amir Khan's,
everybody.
Tremendous boxer.
Look how,
how's how excited.
So Amir things,
everything is cool and then you can see it.
He's slowly looks at crazy legs like
bullshit.
Bullshit.
God bless everybody at this gym.
Coach Tony.
Oh,
Steven.
Hey,
bye.
Alright.
Okay Pal.
So here's a mirror.
Um,
Shit.
Trying to be an older fight,
but this is him.
Uh,
in the ring it looks like maybe you're like right after a fight had ended.
Caitlin says,
yes,
your wife's,
but goodness me.
How hard did you have to work to earn that?
Do you want me very hard?
This is the professional game.
No.
You know what I mean?
It's not gonna be easy.
First measure title.
I won't say he's my 13 fight.
I have to do it.
The army's wicked Willie,
the great fire now.
I mean,
you can't take no credit away from him because he was strong.
Just kept pulling forward.
Skillful.
Yeah.
I enjoy it.
I mean,
I love it in there.
Yeah.
I mean,
no matter if it had 12 rounds,
I was just loving every minute.
So interesting to hear.
You know what I mean with that accident.
Right.
Well,
I wasn't expecting that accent to come out of that face.
Oh yeah,
that's the last accident I would have expected.
What did you expect from Americans?
Just like American.
Oh really?
It's just like shocker con's cause
we're getting over anxious by accident.
I went to the brink though the went to the brink.
At one stage.
It looks you're gonna lose that fight.
Never,
never,
never money went down.
No.
You,
I mean that's Bob too for you.
I mean,
one change.
It could have changed my boy
and I can come up for me from what was going on.
You,
I mean,
when I,
when I did get on me,
this might be a record setting.
Oh,
Maine.
Uh,
find as far as as they go.
I didn't know this and this crosses genre.
I mean,
you've got,
oh,
a white guy who was a boxer and he's saying,
you know,
and he's not a white guy.
What are you talking about?
Yeah.
About,
well,
what is he,
Tom?
That guy looks like a white guy to,
you know,
are you serious right now?
I didn't want to guess because the million
songs will be made and clips.
We'll be isolated.
Well,
I mean,
what part of Amir Khan's look,
it says white guy.
I don't know.
I mean,
what is he then Tom
and I guess he is a Pakistani descent.
Oh yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
yeah,
but he's obviously British raise,
right?
Yeah.
But why don't you do the master of accents,
aren't you then?
Is He British?
Yeah,
he's a born in which region do you hear though?
I here.
I had mentioned to Manchester,
Manchester,
Birmingham,
maltis.
You know what I mean?
So I did it perfect.
That was perfect.
Yummy,
Yummy Manchester.
I mean,
he will put you on the show me,
but I judge component my cell phone.
Just pick the right shots.
Shots.
I like it.
A lot of mistakes when you
go right for you out.
I think the timing just wasn't there,
you know?
I mean,
I,
the timing just wasn't there,
you know what I mean?
But anxious,
anxious,
his white to commit myself to much,
you know,
I mean,
wine just jumped them working myself.
Buying is mash,
you know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
Do your deer.
It's a bit of a wiffle.
There's a Babel,
wherefore Edon it
should I checked
penny,
you want me?
You know what I mean?
For me,
I mean,
do you want me to you?
I mean tell me and go.
I mean,
do you want me to,
you know what I mean?
Definitely.
I think because in your world they're all different.
He might've,
Amir has risen to the top as far as you know,
what I means,
he's the king of,
you know what I mean?
This guy has set the bar super high,
super high.
It's going to really take a strong opponent the same way it does in the ring to
dethrone.
Amir Khan from the,
you know what I mean?
Title,
this White Guy,
Amir Khan,
this title and he's Pakistani,
which is unique.
I don't think we've ever had a Pakistani,
you know what I mean?
He's number one.
He's number one through 10 on,
you know what I mean?
For Pakistani people,
we've never had that.
Absolutely.
Generally same.
Yeah.
Not,
not a lot of writing.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Well,
you know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
Shit.
Okay.
All right.
We're going to roll out anything you want to do.
Be Good.
Get straight.
Is that going to play at the beginning?
The one that you had loaded for the US?
Totally different.
Keep pushy in training,
but it's in the drops.
Oh,
so it's in an email.
Okay.
And then the crazy lugs,
Kate,
push in from those [inaudible] to the rapid training.
That's it.
Kate.
Better that way.
Yeah.
That's a better song.
Wrapping.
Okay.
Kate,
anything else?
Jeans?
No,
I love you.
How am I happy SMURF Day.
I'm glad that you lived 37 years.
Yeah.
You don't look a day over 47 I hope you live at least five more.
No,
I hope you live along.
The child is crying.
I know he's probably getting ready for her to get out of the crate.
You can't just leave him in there for this whole show.
All right,
we got to run.
Thanks for listening to the show.
Amaze.
Keep pushing you.
I'll see you in spoke Compton spokes from can spur him.
Can I buy my jeans?
Oh,
hello.
Eh?
Anybody playing or watching the afternoon TV show?
I had it scored or in bed and got on me.
The band and Brett
came black.
No,
I got him on the bedspread and I had to wash the best way.
You know,
wasn't done body.
Oh,
oh,
ready?
Okay.